when it comes to the representation of
entrepreneurship in popular politics
you're largely stuck with either the
hollow romanticism of the noble small
business owner from conservatives or the
leftist caricature of entrepreneurship
as ultimately a form of predation but
for many entrepreneurs starting a
business is neither of those things for
them it's
an act of existential self-assertion
let's go meet a couple of entrepreneurs
that embody this idea of business as a
means of flourishing we'll start with
chris vigilante who owns a coffee house
and wholesale bean business just outside
of dc
i had all these internships and jobs
growing up that i just it man
work wasn't fun in any regard
huge defining moment in my life when i
decided to make that shift and do
something i was passionate about
i knew i wanted to write my story really
write my own story
i didn't want to act out a script that
somebody handed me
it was the distinct decision to go a
different route than everyone else
i really love what i do
and i think it shows up in the work
next there's nick he's also a millennial
aged entrepreneur who found his means of
making a dent in the universe in a
decidedly old school business nick is a
fifth generation washingtonian who
started a delicatessen right here in the
heart of the capitol
you know i started cooking when i was
about 15 years old in dc restaurants and
i was like totally enamored by the
physicality of it and excitement of the
kitchen the energy of the kitchen the
characters in the kitchen like all that
really drew me in
it's the reason we chose the name
district grocery store is because it was
the first generation jewish immigrants
into the dc started this cooperative
stores the district grocery stores
and they were pushed out of the
traditional buying cooperative so they
built their own
you know taking back sort of the roots
of building for yourself
the same impetus they came here and like
let's build a new life i think this is
my opportunity to actually make an
imprint and do something that's my own
and actuate my own vision
and finally we got shivana who started
an e-commerce company in virginia
internet entrepreneurs are kind of
uniformly lionized by libertarians as
these world-beating randian superheroes
but that thin portrait doesn't really do
justice to shyvana's work far from using
the internet to
disrupt traditional industries she's
actually harnessing its incredible
connectivity to bolster traditional
brick and mortar businesses
i've been sort of building websites and
things on my own since i was maybe 11 or
12. really seen this big opportunity in
the
super outdated floral industry my
company is called bloompop an online
e-commerce marketplace platform making
it just as easy to buy from the local
forest as it is from one of these other
big networks
local florists basically tend to not
invest a lot of time and resources into
keeping up on that space
you know they have really outdated
websites or they don't have e-commerce
so it actually makes it really difficult
people even if they want to purchase
from local florists
i think the local florists with their
really unique designs and their really
unique stories were getting shoved to
the side when they shouldn't have been
it's been really great to see that we've
been able to actually have an impact
most entrepreneurs don't fit into either
caricature of popular politics these are
people that bravely bucked professional
inertia in order to chase their dreams
again i think it just comes back to
writing your own script controlling your
destiny